foreign
[Music]
whoa your camera looks super green
what'd you do oh it's the back lighting
I I alternate between blue green and red
[Music]
to have a green tip
yeah depending on my mood you know if
I'm if I'm in a dark mood and I'm in a
slump it's red
if I'm playing well it's blue and you
know otherwise it's green what is green
do
green green is I get to work with very
talented players who prepare them for a
tournament for sure for sure
um I am actually playing Iceland I'm
excited have you ever played Reykjavik
yes oh Rick open yes I played in 2015
just once
okay okay now how was it do you like it
I played once before too and I really
liked it
fantastic so uh first of all Reykjavik
itself is like an experience Just
landing in the airport your mouth is
you're like oh my God
yeah obviously the weather is something
to get used to I still have a screenshot
on my phone the wind one of the days was
100 kilometers per hour it was very hard
to get to the playing Hall which was 10
steps from the hotel
it was literally walking through the
wind you were walking and you literally
had to grab on to like rail it you know
like uh fire hydrants and stuff I've
never experienced that and it was just
normal when I played it wasn't so bad I
mean it feels like March April is a good
time for Iceland but I guess you know
you know you never know what's gonna
happen with the weather you never know
but the tournament itself like the
organization obviously as you would
expect from Iceland is impeccable the
fish uh is some obviously you don't go
to a tournament for the restaurants
although I kind of do the the seafood is
like you know mouth-watering it's
incredible so definitely like get the
fish uh I don't know if you're a fish
eater food was so at the hotel I was
staying when I played there was this
pizza that was potato leek pizza and
it's one of the best pizzas I've ever
had I don't know why it was so good
because they made the potatoes super
crispy so it adds a crunch and then they
added some little sauce on top of the
weekend it was amazing it was so many
weird combinations of foods but I I love
them I don't think I've ever had a
potato on pizza but uh I'm not a big
fish fish eater by the way and in
Iceland it was amazing I'll have to try
so where would you recommend getting
food from fish plate of yours it was uh
I wouldn't remember like the because it
was there was a weird uh setup where
they gave me like vouchers so you could
only use them at certain restaurants
um oh yeah I don't think that too I did
get pizza on the following day I think
most of the restaurants I went to there
are really good obviously like Reykjavik
is a super expensive city but
um yeah basically I don't think I had a
single bad like day in in Reykjavik
that's awesome my best friend is
actually flying out at the
end I'm actually gonna be a tourist
which is going to be awesome because
last time I didn't explore no absolutely
you should go to the like blue geysers
or whatever they're called there's the
famous Blue Lagoon I went to the Blue
Lagoon with Anna Rudolph last time it
was nice but it I thought it was a
little bit overrated overblown yeah I'm
gonna ask the locals where they go it
was there were some factories and it
felt like it was a you know an
artificial Lagoon it was still nice and
it had a spa but I want to go where the
locals go this time
I see I see keep you updated please do
I'll be following your games obviously
uh but it's a nice tournament I think
you'll have a good time
thank you thank you I'm excited um okay
all right quickly set up everything do
you want to uh send me the invite for uh
sure would you like me to put to turn on
my camera on Discord and disable it on
my stream or how what setup would you
prefer
or are you good with just your camera I
can totally do that
do you want we could just you wait each
other's cameras after that's
okay I'm down to keep it simple
let's do that I'll I'm inviting you now
I've got some cool material
so
um first things first I have to give you
this warm-up exercise it's I had a hard
time solving this
so I'm gonna give it to me so I'm gonna
but there's a caveat it's not just a
regular tactic just okay just send you
the invite
okay
um
hang on let me accept
it's loading I said yes awesome oh I
think it's just taking a second yeah
okay
um well before we get into it maybe we
introduced before I'll introduce the
format quickly one more time for anybody
who's new good idea you guys know this
is Grand Master noraditski I am around
Master Level strength so we basically do
these training exercise so you can see
the difference in thinking we're also
going to give you guys time in the chat
so you could think about it
um and if you want to see Daniel's point
of view I I linked his twitch stream in
the chat
awesome that was a very succinct
description
um obviously I as I mentioned on my
stream some of the exercises are are
challenging so you know people shouldn't
expect uh you know made into actually
they should expect made in twos as we're
about to see uh but the point here is to
challenge ourselves and uh expand our
thinking and hopefully people in the
chat will will be able to do the same
so this kind of blew my mind uh it was
given to me by a friend it's white to
play and maintenance three moves
wow
um made in three there's no it's not one
of those you know I hate those troll
problems oh you got a castle and where
you gotta like move your king to A7
the I hate those it's actual made in
three
um so I'll give you some time to think
about it white spawns obviously you
should face white whites going up
and uh black is currently stalemated so
uh that's sort of your jumping off point
uh in peace so you can think aloud and
uh you know I'll let you I'll let you
get off the ground and then maybe I
could add some some things along the way
perfect so maybe I'll think out loud and
then you can correct or see
um obviously it's gonna be a little bit
slower if I do that but I think it's
better anyway for people watching no
worries
Okay cool so as Donya said black doesn't
have any moves here
or up you know three pieces
um so the obvious way to start thinking
about these is to just start oh do you
mind giving me Arrow privileges
you know I'll think about it I'm just
kidding give full control there we go
thank you thank you okay
any other requests Alexander is so
demanding I mean Jesus send me a coffee
please I need more caffeine
um okay Knight f8 Bishop G8 those are
the checks we see right away the other
ideas I could go for if it's stalemate
is you know to move one of the pieces uh
like Knight F4 so that I give black an
option I don't love that though because
then you have to start calculating all
the pawn pushes as well
um okay so I I'm gonna sit here for a
second and actually I'm just gonna start
thinking through the chips okay so
there's Bishop G8
King takes uh which looks for us right
now check and then the problem with that
is if the King goes back you can't mate
because he takes the Knight so that's
probably not a maiden three okay then
there's Knight f8 check he plays King h8
um and then the only check I have that
isn't repeating the position would be
Rook takes H6 Pawn takes
and that doesn't end in me either so the
first two checks seem to not work
um okay what else
Knight f8 and Bishop G8 have been ruled
out
yep exactly so the immediate checks
don't work
um okay next options I I talked about
moving the Knight and there's also
moving the bishop so that we're not
actually stalemating so uh for example
there's the idea of Bishop E8 which
forces King to G8
um and then
what am I going to do from there
is there anything
Rook F6
but even it just takes yeah or even King
age seven even King age seven exactly
neither of those work um so so I I could
go deeper into this but as of right now
I don't think Bishop E8 Works nope yeah
you're right because you ultimately need
like a Target Target mating position and
with the bishop on E8 the only way to
Checkmate the King on H7 is to get the
Rook to h8 and that just seems
unfeasible because you you'll have to go
through stalemate
exactly
um okay
Okay so
to not keep him stalemated is to move
the Knight unless I'm missing something
but that's what I see so far
um and the options for the night we
ruled out Knight f8 so then the only two
options are Knight of four and 95. there
is one more by the way
and Knight h8
oh my God it's
error because there is technically night
h8 King takes Bishop G6 King here and
Checkmate so actually I do need to look
at Knight h8 as well
um what you're doing right now is
exactly how I approach this position and
Knight h8 was my first attempt
okay
um okay so but but then the other issue
with Knight h8 is what if you know yes
push G5 well let's see yeah exactly
um and then I don't if you're not taking
the Knight there's no mating position no
Maiden two and in fact you can extend
this to all of the Night Moves Knight
f4g5 95 G5 we should show that on the
board for people because my chat yeah is
excited at night I'll let you play it
out so what I think studies teach you
because you might be looking and saying
who gives a damn a maiden three you're
up 100 pieces it teaches you a to be
stubborn and B to it forces you to
consider all of the opponent's resources
which I think is the primary uh
instructive uh sort of value of these
types of positions so if King takes h8
you drop the bishop down and it's mate
the problem is that black doesn't have
to cooperate G5 opens up a square and
it's made in four I think but not made
in three
so like check even takes and there's no
mate on the next move you have to go
here and this is already three moves and
this is four moves
okay so we gotta get it exactly three
moves exactly three moves so all night
moves have been ruled out
all right so no more night moves
um
then I guess we need to go let me think
if there's anything else that well that
wouldn't be stalemate oh a move like
Rook F6
okay
F6 is an interesting idea you're giving
up the rook in order to Grant black more
moves then you play King f8 but you
don't get
because then your knight isn't protected
yes but you're on an interesting track
are there any other ways to sack The
Rook for example
right and there are there's Rook A2 okay
um rookie two but and then but first let
me see if there is a way to even
check with to checkmate with the bishop
and the Knight
um
I mean if you didn't have a rook here
you couldn't check me as far as I see
okay
so
um that is the human assumption that is
the human okay
[Music]
look very carefully after Rook A2 B
takes A2
your brain is telling you this makes no
logical sense to give up lyric how could
there be an additional pattern when The
Rook is off the board
yeah that's exactly what my brain is
saying Dania but force yourself to
consider like ask yourself what are the
new moves that you have in that position
that you wouldn't have previously
um well
um the pawn is way too slow so we're not
gonna try to do that
uh
now the cool thing is that black has an
extra move so we don't have to worry
about stalemate true
but there's no mating pattern with the
bishop in the night and the black king
on H7
yeah let's make the moves on the board
okay
there is no mating path you'll have
you're about to have a light bulb moment
and you're gonna be like oh my gosh
you're gonna hate me after this
uh
um
oh I see it
that's very cute that's very cute it's
very pretty yeah so you take the pawn
I'll play it out and then black takes
that's ridiculous but it's very
beautiful it's beautiful I could not get
it so I needed I needed to know the
first move
I mean yeah the the human sentiment here
is like oh there's no way to mate
because you've already looked at it
before so you're not considering the
change in position with uh B takes A2
right exactly and so much of like
thinking is developing the ability to
detect small details and how they impact
the position
yeah that's um this is very cute I'm
going to turn this into a short
oh absolutely I mean look at the crazy
you have to give up the rook in the
night and that's the only way to
checkmate
damn um that's a very cute puzzle thank
you for sharing it
figured we'd start with this one to sort
of set the tone um and I know it's like
brutally difficult
it is but it's so pretty
so it's I think it's worth it
yeah I feel like if you give people
difficult tactics it has to be beautiful
so at least you feel good when it's over
yeah exactly exactly
um okay so I have a lot of cool
materials starting position one more
time definitely it came in late and then
definitely so
um before we go into the the actual
exercises the rest of them which done it
you haven't seen the next exercises
right you're also going to be working
that's right
okay good good um yeah so it was
Checkmate in three from this position
white to move
okay cool back to you
yeah Checkmate in three from this move
and uh people who came in late can can
do the thinking on their own so I'm
thinking we should do one more warm-up
exercise this is supposed to be a little
bit on the easier side where this comes
from is uh a book called The Manual of
Chess combinations volume two
now I did some of these puzzles about
you know 10 years ago so I don't
remember a single one of them I promise
uh I don't know the solution to any of
the exercises that we're about to do
so we're gonna start with an end game
study that's a little bit less
outlandish than the one we just solved
wait all right this was the easy one
no no this was this was on the harder
side for sure the next one that I'm
about to paste in I think is supposed to
be a little bit a little bit more
straightforward so okay I just pasted it
in it is sorry can you give me a second
I just realized I don't I'm not gonna
have your audio in the VOD so I'm fixing
it now oh okay okay no worries it's okay
I'll take it from yours um all right
we're good
all right so this is white to play and
win
white to play and win
at least this one is more interesting
because you're down material but yeah
you have checkmating chances
and you know that you know you know this
one or you have no no no no I I don't I
don't know the solution to this one I'm
sorry okay so should we do that thing
where we think for two three minutes and
then we talk out loud
yes I think we should do that
oh shoot uh sorry I have somebody who's
who SE uh coming to help me unpack and I
forgot and I left her locked up no
worries go do your thing no rush at all
one second take your time no rush
so I'm gonna I'm gonna start thinking in
the meantime
um I'm gonna mute myself in Discord
or actually no I want Alex's people to
hear me
um so it's white to play and win white
spawns are going this way folks
um what's going on here well the black
king is checkmated
so I was suppose the target position
involves getting the Rook around to H2
so the most obvious move to me is Rook
F4 or Rook H Rook F2
I'm actually going to mute myself in
Discord so Alex's folks can think on
their own
um how is black going to defend after
Rook F2
well Rook H2 is Unstoppable black can
move the king up to H5 so that tells me
Rook F4 prevents King H5 because then
Rook H4 is still Checkmate Rook F4 the
only move I think is Bishop to D1
only move is Bishop to D1 to block the
check
so I'm gonna put a timer or did you
already start thinking I started a
little bit but but you should put a
timer
okay and I will mute myself in Discord
so I can think aloud on my own stream
Perfect all right all right I'm putting
it up here we go good luck
all right so where were we we were
considering and I won't draw arrows
because Alex would see them Rook F4
Bishop D1
Rook H4 check Bishop H5 G4 Rook F3 so
the white king is pushed away there
huh Rook F4 Bishop D1
I feel like Bishop E2 I feel like the
bishop E2 somewhere is going to be
winning but where
Rook F2 Bishop D1
huh I've got four Bishop D1
just make sure this is the right
position
yeah it is okay
we've got four Bishop D1 Rook H4
page five Bishop B2 Rook takes E2
okay F2 Bishop q1
it had there had some gonna be some
bishop move at some point that
intercepts blackstroke where
four Bishop D1
well you can't start with Bishop E2
because the Rook is hanging can't start
with Bishop E2 because the Rook is
saying
so it has to be a move of The Rook Rook
F2 Bishop D1
Rook H2 Bishop H5 oh I got it oh my God
I think I got it it's Rook F2 Bishop D1
Rook H2 Bishop uh H5 Bishop E2
Force The Rook onto E2 and then go G4
and it's mate with G5 because black
can't give the check on the f file
anymore if he does then we take the Rook
the bishop takes the pawn Rook H2 Bishop
H5
and in that position
um okay I I got it there you can
basically force zuke's mom you can just
wait until black gives up the E Pawn
yeah okay I got it that is insane we
will folks obviously when we reconvene
we're gonna make all the moves on the
board so if you're watching this and
you're lost don't worry because we will
make the moves on the board what I'm
doing now is giving you a window into
how I actually think about these types
of exercises
which hopefully is you know interesting
yeah I think it's Rook F2 Bishop D1
Rook H2 Bishop H5 then the point is lack
is threatening Rook F3 check so you have
to deflect The Rook onto a square such
that The Rook will not be able to check
the white King on the f file Bishop E2
Rook takes C2 and then the key is to see
the the pawn mate with G5
so it's definitely Rook F2 it's not Rook
F4 okay I'm gonna pause it's almost
three minutes and okay sorry I was
thinking chat I was thinking in my head
um
Okay so
I notice obviously we're trying to
Checkmate the black king So ideas like
Rook F4 and Rook F2 with the idea of
trying to Checkmate I look at the online
Rook F2
um King H5
Rook uh sorry Bishop E2 and then after
black takes Rook takes
um I mean this this looks pretty good
for for white but
yeah it's 50 50 type of position yeah
exactly because it feels like black can
trade off for G3 and then this is going
to be a draw so I think it seems like it
wasn't good enough
I agree completely after King H5
um I think there is a clean mate here
because it's important I think to detect
small differences so I looked at this
for a second and I realized that well
what is Black's alternate defensive
method here I just saw it because it's
King H5 and then
Rook F4 Bingo Rook F4 we should probably
play it out now black has no way to
block the Checkmate on H4 so Rook takes
G3 eliminating the support of the H4
square is the only move and now Bishop
E2 check forces black to give up The
Rook otherwise it's checkmate
right on H4 interesting so this is
basically combining what you learn with
the when you look at this position
because you're also considering Rook F4
but then the problem is Bishop D1 and
you're blocking on H5 so what you're
trying to do is you get the king there
to block block the square first right
but of course after Rook F2 I thought
the the sort of other defense here was
Bishop D1 anyway
and did you consider this or were you
more focused on King H5
I thought Rook F2 didn't work
five
I gotcha so uh sorry sorry no no I
thought Rook F2 didn't work because of
Bishop D1 oh okay okay so I think why
the other variation seems to fix it
which is Rook F4
yes so how do things work after Rook F4
I play Bishop D1
and what was your intention here
because Rook H4 still Bishop H5 right
yeah yeah right it's still a problem and
I think it's a bit of a dead end so I
think it is Rook F2
I think it is Rook F2 and after Bishop
D1 what is like the the most tempting
idea what are the two moves that they
seem to win the game if you look very
superficially
well stuff like Rook h2g
go ahead
get out on the board so people can see
what we're talking about so this is the
idea that obviously you want to look at
first but then after Rook F3 check
you're pushing the king away so I don't
see how we're we're gonna end up better
here because you just trained you end up
trading everything yeah and it's exactly
in fact black is playing for the win
there
yeah okay wait why is black playing for
the win here
well not really but I mean I I'm
threatening Rook F4 I could see white
losing this in a bullet game
okay sorry
of course white should play King E5
yeah
obviously right chat
of course of course why I mean well I
mean to be like on and honest here you
know you know what what is playing for
the win but you know with that being
said so in any case after Bishop H5 I
think it's a critical position after
Black Blocks the check
because here I sort of tried to problem
solve like is there a way to forcibly
prevent
oh my God yeah you got it Bishop E2 yeah
I love the light bulb yeah Bishop E2 is
Right wow this is I think it is one
Bishop B2 Rook takes C2
and then you push G4 yeah I think that's
what it is
but it goes on Rook F2 I thought Rook
takes F2
so Rook H2 check of course Bishop H5 and
here I generated a Target position which
is that here's the thing if Black's
e-pawn is gone
then I think white has a winning move
which is to step down to F5
yep and give black The Runaway Square so
that you could take the bishop so my
second Observer yeah so you have to
force the E Pawn to be given away
I was gonna say I want my brain to work
the way your brain does I don't know if
that's okay I think if you see how my
brain works you'll be like I don't know
about this thing ah you get the chest GM
but you know you always break a few
mouses here and there that's exactly
right
so how do we get rid of the e-pawn
without allowing black out of the cage
okay well that is
a bit of a predicament
um Okay so
so let's say we're just keeping the Rook
on the H file
um and then he keeps pushing at what
point would it be okay for us to take
the pawn
um
and we have to do it with the Rook yep
yep it feels like if the Pawn's on E3 we
should be able to take it because then
oh no oh because we need to be able to
come back with check
okay so we basically need to take it on
a light Square then
I agree 100 and you can take it on e4
yep you can take it on e4 exactly so
something like this
Bingo and
back
he goes here you make space for the king
and then you win
I think that's what it is wow this is a
pretty tactic how long does it take you
to find uh most of I I was stumped the
first like minute and a half I kept I I
knew that Bishop E2 was probably
involved because it's also like a
classic study motif
so uh the position after Bishop H5
stopped me for a while that the third
movie you put it back there no worries
the third move Bishop E2 is what took me
the longest and I honestly think one of
the reasons I solve these is just I'm
like stubborn as hell
and in certain critical positions I just
refuse to admit that the line doesn't
work I've noticed this in my lessons as
well I don't think it's that I see more
tactical patterns I mean I maybe see
them more quickly but I think I'm a lot
more stubborn I think I'm a lot less
inclined to give up on a line just in
general
interesting well yeah I I mean in three
minutes I couldn't go super deep in the
lines but I haven't
I think I asked you about this before
but when you're calculating lines do you
look at all of them kind of surface and
then go and then you go deeper into the
ones you like but do you come back to
your lines or do you try to solve it all
the way through the first time you're on
it I would say two things uh I do try to
solve it all the way through if I see a
promising first move like if I see a
move that seems promising I will I won't
you know start looking at the other
candidate moves until I've exhausted the
line
but what I also try to do is when I
consider other candidate moves I try to
extract information from a line that
doesn't work I don't think people do
this enough like you calculate a line
that fails but you know in that line you
might have discovered an interesting
idea that could be applied in a
different first candidate move
so for instance you might have been
calculating you know Rook F4 and maybe
in this line you spotted the idea of
advancing the g-pawn to G5 with
Checkmate and then of course the same
idea is applied in this position so a
lot of lines are connected and you have
to extract information even from lines
that fail I think
that makes sense and that's why the
bishop E2 is so key because the problem
um with any of those variations was that
black would get some kind of check on F3
so that was the only way to not get that
exactly exactly are you up for one more
income study or should we go to the
middle game I I love end game studies
so let's do what they're in agreement
yep right now can be either like really
easy or really hard let's see which one
it is
white to play and win
okay here it is I don't see it yet but
I'll let it come up on the board
ooh white to play and win let's do this
thing yes
okay all right I'm gonna think for three
minutes
uh and then and then I will start
talking again same here I'll mute myself
in Discord okay perfect
all right
let's do this thing so what do I see
well
obviously if we take the Rook black
plays Bishop F2 check and wins our rook
and that's a draw first move I see is
Rook to E8 check but then the king moves
to F7 and hits our rook and if we go
Rook B8 there then black always has this
check on F2
are there any other checks Bishop C4
check what we could try to do is get the
Rook on a light square with check so
that we could pick up blackstroke and we
don't lose our own so Bishop C4 check if
the king moves to f8 then Rook F1 wins
if the king moves to H eighth and rookie
a check wins so Bishop C4 check where
can black go King G7
rookie seven Shaq
okay I gotta think here King f8
seeing our Fates
Rook F7 check King E8
huh
King H5 let's see Bishop C4 King G7
rookie seven King f8
doesn't seem too promising what about
rookie a check rookie h a king F7
uh no I don't like that either
let's go back to Bishop C4 King G7
I just gotta think in silence
oh I think I got it
I think I got it wait
check there there
I think I got it
yeah so I think it is Bishop C4 check in
G7 rookie seven check
there's also King F6
that has to be considered then rookie
six Jack King F5
and you just move your king that's got
to be winning
that's got to be winning so Bishop C4
check King G7 rookie seven check King f8
Rook F7 check King E8 I think it's Rook
F6
Bishop d8 Bishop B5 check yeah I'm
pretty sure that's it
it's not like a beautiful tactic but
there is a very pretty
theme in the middle there
yeah so I think it's Bishop C4 King G7
rookie seven King f8 Rook F7
King E8 and then I think the critical
move that's easy to miss is Rook back to
F6 hitting the bishop but then there's
Bishop d8 pinning The Rook against the
king and then white has the intermediate
move Bishop B5 check
so I think that's the critical idea
like you know the
you'll go nice in the previous one but I
think it's super instructive
all right all right
three minutes is up all right
Okay so
I see that we're attacking The Rook we
can't take right away because Bishop F2
checking the rook and the king
um and ultimately the other important
thing about this position is even if we
somehow win a pawn it's still probably
gonna be a draw if we trade off Rooks
so then the question is is there any way
to get out of this check and the most
promising line looked like something
Bishop C4 100 you can't go to f8 because
you check and you take the Rook the king
can't go to h8 because you check on E8
and then you take the Rook so the only
option is King G7 and I was working on
figuring this out all the way through
um but I think this is a position I
started getting stuck at yep uh so this
so far I'm in agreement so here I
thought rookie six check is logical
and I think
I think difficult spots in this study
too King F5 black has to have to keep
contact with the Rook again I think it's
important not to be stubborn in regards
to the goal because I formulated the
goal as winning black stroke but winning
the bishop is also a way to win the game
I think if you think of it that way the
move is very clear
you just need to step out of the check
basically disturbing
yes I see it now
so you're right you're right
so what's what move do you think it is
here because I think there's a trap you
have to avoid okay yeah so so we don't
want Bishop F2 and we also don't want to
play Rook H5 and have excellent okay one
work so then you have to play King H3
you have to play King H3 black can try
H5 but now I think a simple move
reinforces the threat of Bishop takes A6
um let's see where do we want to move
our Rook we want to move our Rook
somewhere where the king can't attack it
so the only square is E6 I think that's
so this position is winning for sure
because Black's Rook can't move away
with check
ugh you make it seem so easy but there's
another line by the way it was close and
I felt like I was close but I I didn't I
didn't make it all the way to the end
yet you totally would with like an
additional two minutes so I feel like
you're getting the Crux of this there's
also the King f8 which has to be
considered yeah yeah for sure
um so let's take a look at that one too
so King f8 and I mean
the moves that I think you have to
consider here are I mean it has to be
Rook F7 yes oh Rook F7 and then the king
isn't gonna move to G8 because there's
discoveries they moved E6 and then Rook
f
6 Bishop d8 oh Bishop d8 you're right
nope you need to be careful wait but
remember stubbornness you know you don't
abandon the lines
never abandoned the line Rook F6 Bishop
d8
oh
wow wow okay this should be fine check
forcing the king ugh it's disgustingly
beautiful it's amazing Bishop B5 check
is I think the key movement is beautiful
yeah
oh wow that's very cute don't abandon
lines
God I love these studies that have where
the beauty is of a different kind than
the previous one I think
it is it is no these are just so
satisfying at the end
they really are they really are
um okay so so I mean you solved this one
and your big switch was realizing that
you could just win the bishop yes that
was the first biggest thing which was
that I I wasn't in my mind saying if I
don't win The Rook it's lost I
understood that if you get a situation
like this and you can force the black
group to move it's important also to
realize that the white Bishop is
defending the pawn because if black
could win the pawn rook and Bishop
versus Rook is a drop but with the pawn
on the void it's totally winning and
then the second thing was the
stubbornness to find Bishop B5 check
that makes sense
um and yeah I think that's that's one
thing when you're calculating a plan
um you know until you're a grand master
a very strong player it's easy to tunnel
on one thing you're trying to do
yeah
but yeah exactly exactly
um but broadening the goal is super
important
yes yeah that makes sense this is a cute
one I like the end game studies they're
very fun wanna do one more game study
let's do it all right so I want to I
want to find one I just want to get one
no you're getting the Right Moves In all
of them I think three minutes is just
not a lot of time for solving studies
but I still think we're you know
producing instructive value yeah and
we're making progress totally and I
think this next one
you know what I feel like you know when
you're um in the gym and you're lifting
a weight and you can't lift it anymore
and then you have somebody who helps you
bring it all the way to the top spotter
mental exercises yeah I just don't
believe in like super easy exercise as
satisfying as it is like what is the
instructive value of doing puzzles that
you can get in like 10 seconds you know
the interesting thing is that you said
you should do puzzles that are 300 ELO
above your Chestnut composil rating and
Hammer says 300 euo below so is that an
interesting contradiction there very
interesting I mean my caveat is that of
course you should do warm-up exercises
and there should be some time dedicated
to just maintenance of your skills but I
was speaking about the sort of main
phase of your training but there's many
methods
it's okay I'm not trying to start beef
oh you should speak between you and Don
no I I think it's great
okay so this is it white to play and win
white to plan one I I see people in my
chat asking for his camera we have his
stream title his stream name in the
title you can click on it and you can
see both Okay cool so so should we do
the thing where we think for three
minutes wait you said white to move and
win yes I'm as surprised as you are
yeah that's oh okay all right all right
good luck I'm gonna start the time luck
Okay so
there's two ways to win this game
there's Checkmate and you need to win
the queen but you can't let black
recapture The Rook okay so Rook D1 is
ruled out blacks King moves aside
and if you take the queen then only
black can win that position so I feel
like it has to be Knight C7 check that's
the only move which makes sense so if
King D4 then we fork with the Knight if
King E5 then we go rookie one check
if King F6 then there's another Fork on
E8 so the King has to go to F4
96 check forces the king to G4
ah but then if we go Rook G1 check black
is Queen G3 I
okay that doesn't work crap
I thought that was it
hmm
Knight C7 King E5 rookie one king F4
96 King G4 Rook G1 Queen G3
maybe we found a mistake in the in the
exercise
wait a minute if it's not that then what
on Earth is it
maybe it's a mistake in the study
because if black didn't have Queen G3
then it would be winning for white
maybe it's some sort of zugz one
no I don't I don't think so
I think this might be a flawed study
which is very instructive in its own
right by the way
holy smokes
let's see if Alex is stumped on the same
idea this would be awesome
yeah I think it's wrong
Alexandra I gotta cut you off for a
second
okay I think this is a flawed study but
I'm curious if you're stumped on the
same move that I am
uh I'm I'm deep into variation right now
I can tell you where I've gotten yeah
tell me where you're where you're going
because I'm deep into variation and I
think this is a mistake in the study
I've confirmed this is the right
position
okay so I mean I was looking into this
line uh Knight C7 yep uh I'm just gonna
play the line that I thought was the one
that was the most tricky yeah yeah this
position here and then I was looking at
check and it works at King H5 but I was
trying to figure out what to do after
King H3 here it works as well see a draw
but there is a mate there there's a man
there okay well this is where I had
gotten but there's a there's something
crazy which is that in this position
black is a move that refutes the line
Queen G3 Queen G3
I think I didn't even think about that
yet I think this was missed by the
composer of the study I'll check the
solution but you should find the mate
after King H3
okay yeah this is where I was oh I
uh
almost okay let me find it people in my
chat confirming this is uh this is
winning for black actually after Queen
G3 oh yeah
oh no
sorry
so check check King H2
um
oh I see it okay
yeah very cute yeah yeah okay but this
is where I was without moving the pieces
so I was just trying to figure out king
H3 because I had seen the lines until
then but I also missed Queen V3 and so
did the study composer this is V kaushik
1906 and I'm reading the solution and
the solution misses Queen G3
down
wow and you know it was 1906
. Circle this because there are some
people who collect fault wrong studies
so I'm going to write I'm going to note
this down
extremely nerdy
but you correct them yeah it was wrong
like I looked at the study and he missed
the move so it's an invalid oh man
that's very funny you know what that
means though
what does that mean that means we got to
do hopefully one that has a proper
solution yeah I was so close I felt like
I was gonna finally get an end game
study but that's so amazing how the
study composer it's the power of your
brain like making assumptions right like
oh the King has to move in response to
Rook G3 that's a whole nother topic
which is the importance of like not
letting your brain kind of dictate you
know push you around
um and really pausing on every position
no that's true and then when you're
solving the puzzle you you know there's
a solution so you're just going through
what you think the solution would look
like
which is why you know training puzzles
and puzzles in real life is always so
different oh 100 and I think our next
set of exercises is really going to help
address that
um but Let's do let's do one more study
okay
um white to play and white to play and
let me see and win
okay okay
um all right you know you are making it
a little easier because you could have
just said white to play but I'll take it
but I also am saying it wouldn't be fair
because I'm seeing plus minus on the in
the book
yeah and uh
all right
good luck perfect thank you you too
all right here we go so
um
what do I see here well we could take
the Knight but then black takes B2 and
that seems like an unclear position
probably white is better but it's not
going to be totally winning Rogue B4
comes to mind because you can't take the
Rook Queen C8 Rook B8 you can't take the
Rook again so where does the queen go
after Rook before Queen C8 Rook B8 well
it has to go to H3
then there's Rook h8
the queen is no squares
but black and go Knight H4 wait black
and gold Knight H4 Rook takes H4
black and go Queen C8
and then you go to h8 again Queen B7
Rook B8 oh that's unreal
you do that six times and you trap the
queen
oh that's so pretty Rook takes H4 Queen
C8 Rook h8 Queen B7 Rook B8 Queen A7
Knight C6 check so you chase the queen
around the entire board using the
technique of sacking a rook because the
Rook can't be taken due to a fork on C6
or on G6
yeah I mean it's a concept that
everybody should be familiar with and I
know this concept from studies so it's
not hard because I've solved a million
of these studies maybe you have as well
where you have to chase the queen around
with a rook that's constantly hanging
and it can't be captured so this is an
easier one because it's the same theme
for every move
that is really pretty
really pretty
girl
huh phenomenal
I'm already looking at the next one I
got it
let's hear it
okay so I think it's Rook before I agree
um you can't play Queen A7 because of
Knight C6 uh if you play Queen A8 then
you play Rook B8 either move you're
gonna play Knight C6 you're up enough
pawns so that's winning
um so of course the mar testing line is
Queen C8 Rook B8 similar idea but then
the black queen has this Escape square
but then it looks like Rook h8 works
because there's nowhere the queen can
run right here there is Knight H4 which
I hadn't seen yet
[Music]
um
and can you just take this or is there
an issue of you take I guess the queen
can go back
uh keep going
and then if the queen goes back
you have probably H3
um
because you should be stubborn oh you
put your Rook back yes then the queen
runs again why is this queen always
running and then he put the rock on yes
yes
it's a beautiful study
Jesus this is this is a lot of Queen
running around the board
um I should probably play it out play it
on the board yeah okay so you can't take
work so the Queen runs away but you say
not so fast and you go rookie Chase but
the queen has another square and that's
when you play Rook B8 again yeah yeah
the river goes back and then this looks
beautiful you know what's incredible
about the study poses these what's this
incredible was I'll tell you who can
post it
it was let me check the the number of
the puzzle it's five
when I'm looking for it they're 557
This was
um droidsky Alexi troitsky one of the
most famous study composers
1910. damn
was he was he Russian yeah so he was he
worked as a Forester like he he lived in
the wilderness and oh he wasn't a chess
player but all he did is compose studies
and some of his like most famous studies
are involved like chasing a queen around
the board
wait really that's so cool yeah that's
right he's awesome
I would estimate if he sat I don't even
know if he has any games in the database
probably like you know I'm sure he was
like 2 000 but no he wasn't a master
damn can you send me can you spell his
name out in our chat so I can look up
some of the studies later yeah uh so
it's t-r-o
it spells several different ways because
it's but the most common English
spelling is
[Music]
t-r-o-i-t-z-k no his first name was not
Leon
um it was Alexi TR no I or y at the end
no I or Y well there is a y t r o tro i
t z k y Troy got it if you search that
in Google you'll find a bunch of but
you'll find a bunch of uh studies okay
cool that's that's a pretty pretty cool
history so but but what's amazing about
this one is how you you literally go on
the same squares like you go to B8 to h8
then to h8 into B8 so yeah no this is a
very beautiful study so awesome yeah
Droid studies are great it's crazy it
would be if you played something like
this in a game unbelievable
cheating that's true so
well there's okay there's one that I'm
that caught my eye which I feel like has
the potential to be beautiful
and it's a it's a minor piece end game
wanna tackle that one and then maybe we
can go to the middle games
a lot of people when they do studies
they're like well it's never going to
happen in the game so what's the point I
think it teaches you a lot of skills
it's not all about solving positions
that are going to happen in your game
none of the positions you solve are
gonna happen in the game
um so I I'm a big believer in studies
I've done Oh I thought you're gonna have
some extra line at the end about why
it's still important
yeah nope it's totally useless
[Music]